stephen is in salt lake city hi steven
welcome to the dave ramsey show
oh thanks for taking my call can you
hear me sure what's up
okay perfect yeah so i have kind of a
two-part question
my wife and i just finished baby step
number two last month
so we're officially debt free good um uh
probably about
four or five months ago in in the middle
of it um her car was a 2005 toyota
corolla broke down
and we had to get a new car so we bought
a
2012 fiat for three grand um
cool and that got us through the rest of
our of our time good um
my question uh my question is though is
that
um i have a car it's worth five thousand
five or six thousand
works well um but i don't really feel
comfortable
leaving her in this three thousand
dollar car how long have you been
uncomfortable with her driving that car
um probably about a month or two into it
when one day she called me and she's
like
it won't turn on we had to bring it in
we had to release the terminal you're
violating federal law though
federal law is wife gets the good car
yeah yeah that's uh that's the bigger
question is that we're on baby step
three no you're calling
she gets your car yep she doesn't know
how to drive it it's a stick
we have a weekend project learn how to
drive
that is true like so ben that is a good
thing to get her into trying to get her
to drive that car
i don't know why you listen i don't want
her driving that freaking hooptie either
so how are we getting her out of it
what's your plan um so my
um two things that are coming up we're
saving up for baby step number three our
three to six months of expenses
good and um i have i'm in college
i'm about to finish community college i
have grants through the rest of the time
so
until this next until next fall i'm not
going to owe anything when i
transfer to an actual university um but
it's going to be about 4 000 a semester
um before i can try to work out any
grant
any new grants or anything but should i
first get her into a new car or should i
do baby step number three
or should i save up for my semesters i
think you can do all three by september
don't you
i i know i can yeah okay then which one
which one's most important
to to me would probably be getting her
into the new car
wrong and i don't know if it's probably
it would be three to six months of
expensive yeah yeah
that's the right answer okay and then
the next answer is her car and then the
next answer is your stuff because your
stuff doesn't you don't have to have it
until september
for sure um another the next question is
we make seventy two thousand a year
before taxes um and
my car is worth about five to six
thousand hers is worth three now
um santa sophia i lived in
italy for about two years where they
manufactured it and i just have a
personal like sentimental value
for this car but you were afraid for
your wife to drive it
i have for her to drive it listen get
you a fiat later when you're rich
right now you're a broke college student
your wife's in a hooptie let's not try
to hold on to this thing let's get rid
of it you need all the dollars you can
get to get her a better car
yeah let's get let's get a sentiment in
your pocket nostalgia is better when you
have some money
that's right yeah there's you can get
you an old fiat i got an old corvette i
got a 1960 corvette
box go get a little matchbox fiat show
full size
i know yours is full grown dave